es war vor genau zehn jahren als ein
tsunami drei bollwerke hinweg spülte
ein japanisches atomkraftwerke an der
pazifikküste die atomenergie in
deutschland bund zwei wochen danach
jahrzehntelange vorherrschaft der cdu in
baden württemberg
obwohl der atomausstieg in deutschland
beschlossene sache ist flammt die
diskussion darüber wieder auf weil eine
vermeintlich saubere atomenergie den
klimawandel aufhalten könnte klimawandel
und energiewende können wir auf die
atomkraft verzichten jetzt nach fünf
stunden
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
es sind uns zugeschaltet professor
claudia kemfert energie-expertin des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung
professor hans werner sinn
wirtschaftswissenschaftler und
ehemaliger präsident des ifo-instituts
hier im studio sitzen oder weiten feld
wirtschaftsjournalistin und krank pass
von frei des vor vier sie müssen
vielleicht noch etwas genauer vorstellen
sie sind seit dem allerersten
klimastreit dabei seit januar 2009 10
organisieren sie diese streiks und sind
seit märz 2009 10 auch gewählt hat
pressesprecher von freiheitskämpfer was
haben sie denn als erstes gedacht als
sie vor zehn jahren dadurch die bilder
des gefluteten und in den nächsten tagen
nach und nach explodierenden
atomkraftwerks in fukushima gesehen
haben
ja ich glaube wie viele andere auch war
das ein erheblicher einschnitt für mir
war sofort klar wie vielen anderen eben
auch dass dies der beginn des endes der
atomenergie weltweit sein wird das wird
sich jetzt noch sehr lange hinziehen
aber es ist ein derart einschneidendes
erlebnis dass dies oder reichlich war
ich erinnere mich aber auch ich hab ja
auch in den in japan geforscht habe dort
auch kollegen die immer sagten dieses
ereignis ist tatsächlich nicht möglich
und es war eingetreten
insofern muss man das auch
energiewirtschaftlich so bewerten die
welt welche erinnerungen haben sie an
diesem tag ja ganz ähnlich wie vor
kämpfe ich glaube dass es relativ klar
war deutschland hat ja ein zu der zeit
eine ganz lebhafte diskussion über
atomkraft sie haben das eben erwähnt vor
den landtagswahlen in baden württemberg
gab es in baden wird vor allem in baden
württemberg große proteste gegen
atomkraft es gab auf der anderen seite
eben den beschluss der damals schwarz
gelben bundesregierung den atomausstieg
von rot-grün vorher wieder rückgängig zu
machen
die entscheidung war daten ein halbes
jahr alt also das thema war öffentlich
total präsent und ich glaube jeder hat
sofort das gefühl gehabt neben dem
schork und dem mitgefühl und auch der
sorge um japanische bürger und um
menschen die ja da zu tode gekommen sind
vor allem durch den tsunami aber daneben
auch durch die atomkatastrophe
neben dieser sorge hatte jeder sofort
das gefühl das ist etwas das seine
auswirkungen auch in deutschland hat und
eben in dieser virulenten debatte damals
hatte man auch das gefühl das bleibt
nicht ohne konsequenzen für den
deutschen wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft
er ist irgendwie hat sie denn diese
atomkatastrophe berührt naja hat einen
großen schreck gekriegt ich habe mich
erinnert an tschernobyl und die
schrecklichen bilder die wir damals
gesehen haben die wolke von tschernobyl
war ja sogar bis nach bayern wo ich
damals schon wohnte gekommen und es hat
hier im fallout gegeben so man durfte
pilze in der eile nicht mehr essen usw
also die gefährlichkeit des geschehens
waren wir schon bewusst erst im
nachhinein habe ich dann erfahren dass
also eine explosion des reaktorkerns wie
in tschernobyl allerdings nicht
stattgefunden hatte sondern nur in
anführungsstrichen eine
wasserstoff-explosion schlimm genug
es hat drei kernschmelzen gegeben vor
zehn jahren man sich glaube ich zehn
jahre alt ist das wichtig was können sie
denn mit fukushima mit dem begriff mit
den namen mit dem ereignis anfangen also
da bin ich auch in allen nicht viel also
ich habe er in der schulzeit erlebt wir
haben über die anti-atomkraft-bewegung
redet wir haben über atomenergie auch im
chemie-unterricht geredet und für mich
und ich glaube auch viele meiner
generation ist eigentlich klar atomkraft
nein danke also wir wollen nicht zurück
zur atomenergie und das sind sachen für
die bewegung und vor uns gekämpft haben
und der gesellschaft der konsens ist
erreicht worden und den wollen wir auch
gar nicht wieder irgendwie aufmachen
das könnte das aber möglicherweise auch
mit den ansprüchen von freilich for
future und den klimaaktivisten
kollidieren weil ja es auch argumente
gibt dass atomkraft möglicherweise den
klimawandel aufhalten könnte wir haben
das ja diese prämisse auch heute
an den anfang der sendung gesetzt
jedenfalls fest steht fukushima war
anlass für eine ziemlich radikale
energiewende in deutschland nicht nur
weil das vorher in die andere richtung
ging mit der schwarz-gelben koalition
sondern weil ja auch tatsächlich eine
jahrzehntealte energieerzeugung an ihr
ende kam diese radikale energiewende
läuft die wände gut oder schlecht wenn
wir jetzt die zeit der letzten zehn
jahre betrachten
naja sie läuft im moment noch ganz
geschmeidig weil deutschland erster
seinen stand des staates sein stabiles
stromnetz nicht nur aus der atomenergie
bekommt sondern weil es eben auch noch
kohlekraftwerke gibt und weil das gas
kraftwerke gibt also wir haben neben den
namen der atomenergie eben noch fossile
brennstoffe die wir verbrennen und die
für die stabilität der stromversorgung
in deutschland auch mit sorgen
da wollen wir aber auch haus und das ist
glaube ich eben die große frage und
darum geht ja die ganze diskussion wenn
man sagt wir wollen möglicherweise
wieder in die atomkraft einsteigen nicht
in deutschland aber in anderen ländern
dass man sagt wenn man aus der kohle
raus geht aus dem öl raus geht aus dem
gas raus geht für die erzeugung von
strom dann hat man möglicherweise am
ende mit einem stromnetz zu tun das nur
erneuerbar nur auf erneuerbaren energien
beruht das aber möglicherweise dann eben
nicht mehr so stabil ist und nicht genug
strom liefern kann die frage was die
regenerative energie tun kann besprechen
wollten die sendung noch genauer
vorkämpfen
es ist ja durch die aufgabe der in
atomenergie ist er noch da bis ende
nächsten jahres werden ja noch etwa ein
halbes dutzend atomkraftwerke strom
produzieren hat man natürlich einem
industrieland einen wichtigen energie
pfeiler weggenommen
bisher hat man nicht das gefühl gehabt
dass das große nachteile gehabt hat aber
möglicherweise könnte das in zukunft
auch vor weiten feld hat er sehr
angesprochenen zusammenhang mit dem
kohleausstieg passieren sind sie sich
sicher dass wir beide energieformen
nicht brauchen
ja ich bin mir sehr sicher wie viele
andere kolleginnen und kollegen auch in
der gier wissenschaftler die das auch in
ihren studien belegen wir können auf
beides verzichten aber wir müssen da
nicht nur ausstiegs
debatten führen sondern einstiegs
debatten nämlich zu einer energiesystem
wende die frau weidenfeld hat zu recht
gesprochen das system basierend auf
erneuerbare energien
schwankungsanfälliger wir brauchen ein
anderes system ist es dezentraler es ist
flexibler wir brauchen eine abstimmung
auch ein energiemanagement ein last
management und mittelfristig auch mehr
speicher technologien und wenn man das
klug miteinander kombiniert ist die
versorgungssicherheit genauso gesichert
und gerade jetzt bezogen auch auf die
atomenergie können wir absolut
entwarnung geben wir könnten heute auch
die restlichen sechs kraftwerke vom netz
nehmen ohne dass die lichter ausgehen
aber wichtig ist dass wir das
energiesystem als ganzes umbauen und da
wünsche ich mir einfach eine debatte die
nicht rückwärts geht sondern möglich
nach vorne
wie schaffen wir die energie systeme her
sind sie sind ja ein kritiker dieses
atomausstiegs jetzt war es aber doch so
gewesen dass bereits vor fukushima wir
eine gesellschaftliche mehrheit gegen
atomenergie gegen die gewinnung der
atomkraft hatten ungefähr so serno bill
man braucht ja auch die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung um das weiterzuführen
hat die politik da richtig agiert jetzt
gerade auch unter diesem eindruck dieser
katastrophe von fukushima oder war das
ein fehler wie jetzt energiepolitik sei
derzeit betrieben wird ja zunächst
einmal eine technische anmerkung ich
höre nur sie ich höre nicht die
zugeschalteten kollegen
die das wird jetzt gerade geklärt haben
wir nicht alles erklären dass er sinn
wenn sie sie sind hier gut zu verstehen
aber sie können in der zwischenzeit
versucht die frage zu beantworten wie
können sie gut hören ja also ich finde
die entscheidung die frau merkel
getroffen hat direkt nach fukushima so
auszusteigen
die entscheidung fiel ja praktisch eine
woche später das war mehrere kurzschluss
entscheidung denn ich vermute sie wird
das heute auch bedauern denn wir können
ja nicht folgen das machen wir können
nicht die atomkraft abschalten
wir können aus der kohle raus gehen und
gleichzeitig wollen wir den verkehr
elektrisch machen und dann auch noch die
häuser elektrisch heizen mit wärmepumpen
also das passt nicht zusammen
die lücke müsste durch den wind und
solarstrom gefüllt werden aber der ist
viel zu volatil als dass er das könnte
ohne dass die anderen kraftwerke stets
in bereitschaft stehen um im falle einer
dunkel flotte zu produzieren
er war zweimal einen aspekt noch im
zusammenhang mit visa im zusammenhang
mit der den atomausstieg noch besprechen
jetzt gerade schon angedeutet das
betrifft natürlich auch freiheit ist
future jetzt ist die atomenergie jahr
hat er einen sehr viel geringeren co2
abdruck als andere energie emissionen
zum beispiel kohle geht aus ihrer sicht
dieser klimawandel dehnt sie ja dringend
für nötig halten wird eine veränderung
der bisherigen klimapolitik denn
wirklich ohne atomkraft jedenfalls als
übergangstechnologie muss man da sofort
raus denn dann würde ja möglicherweise
die brückentechnologie doch ob die da
bis 2038 aus kohlekraftwerken bestehen
das ist ja das was sie auf jeden fall
vermeiden wollen und was ja die
klimabilanz auch richtig ruinieren würde
bei uns das ist ja nicht spannende frage
also wir gehen auf die straßen bei wie
die dringlichkeit sehen dass
klimawandels oder auch dann der
klimakrise oder der klimakatastrophe wir
sehen auch dass die wissenschaftler ganz
klar sagt haben noch zehn jahre warten
bis ihr handeln müssen damit die kipp
punkte noch verhindert werden können
und da ist die rede von
brückentechnologien ich habe das
für ihn in der politik und in der
gesellschaft viel über
brückentechnologien und vergessen dann
in die über erneuerbare energien zu
reden dort zu investieren dort zu
forschen dort ja auch endlich mal an zu
setzen und zu sagen wir investieren
jetzt wenn die erneuerbaren energien und
setzen dort an
und wenn wir jetzt aber ihre
brückentechnologien reden dann dauert
das ja alles und die zeit haben wir ja
gar nicht also ein atomkraftwerk zu
bauen braucht er mindestens 15 bis 20
jahre und auch so co2 neutral ist ja
auch gar nicht da die ressourcen erstmal
irgendwo herkommen
die frage war ja welchen sinn die
atomenergie macht jetzt auch für ihre
überzeugungen was die klimapolitik
angeht wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe
bezieht sich freilich for future ja auch
auf den bericht des weltklimarates und
da wird ja auch atomenergie als eine
mögliche lösung gesehen
die klimabilanz zu verbessern als eine
von vielen ja der city report geht davon
aus dass atomenergie natürlich eine
übergangslösung sein kann aber wir
müssen auch betrachten dass wir jetzt
hier in deutschland diesen
gesellschaften konsens jahrzehntelang
gekämpft haben und da auch ganz klar
gesagt haben atomenergie ist nicht die
lösung und kann auch nicht die lösung
sein und in deutschland vorreiterin in
nrw energien sein soll dann müssen wir
auch ganz klar jetzt darauf setzen auf
dezentrale energiesysteme auf eine
transformation sozial gerecht und da
müssen wir auch ganz klar sagen dass
atomenergie keine brückentechnologie
sondern eher etwas generation
ungerechtes war ja auch wie ihr bis
heute kein endlager haben sie bis heute
keine risikoschutz faktoren haben die
irgendwie solche katastrophen wieder
verändern können
ich glaube in deutschland redet hier
auch im ernst im moment niemand über
einen wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft
wir reden wenn wir über atomkraft reden
in deutschland über die frage können wir
auf nuklearenergie verzichten und dann
gleichzeitigen kauf nehmen dass wir
welche aus frankreich einkaufen oder das
für kohlestrom aus polen einkaufen wenn
wir aus der kohle aussteigen wollen also
es geht um die frage verhalten wir uns
richtig wenn wir auf der einen seite
sagen sohn in unserem hintergarten haben
wir das nicht aber wir kaufen sven uns
wenn es uns eben fehlt von woanders und
herr sinn hat jetzt zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass für zwei wichtige
punkte haben nämlich einmal was machen
wir wenn die sonne nicht scheint der
wind nicht bläst zum beispiel eben in
diesem jahr im februar da war es
unglaublich kalt es war unglaublich
niedlich und dann geraten eben solche
energie
systeme in enorme stresssituation weil
sie eben nicht mehr erneuerbare
einspeisen können die ja inzwischen mehr
als 40 prozent normalerweise jedenfalls
der stromversorgung ausmachen
und zweitens und das ist eine ganz
wichtige frage wenn wir die energiewende
weiter machen wollen in deutschland und
das ist ja eine strom wende sowohl in
der mobilität als auch in der wärme wenn
wir das wollen und das wollen ja alle
dann müssen wir mehr strom haben und
woher der kommt dass es eben
unbeantwortet und zu sagen wir müssen
einfach mehr in wind und sonne
investieren klar das können wir machen
aber wir finden im moment kaum jemanden
der sagt noch so ein windrad wäre super
das will keiner in das wird niemand mehr
haben also die meisten investitionen in
wind onshore also auf dem land werden im
moment verhindert von den leuten die da
wohnen gibt es nicht mehr wollen und so
viel sonne dass es das kompensieren
könnte am in deutschland nicht wenn die
sonne nicht scheint der wind nicht weht
hat möglicherweise frau kämpfen die idee
wie man das kompensieren können den
kleinen moment mit callte dunkel führte
den begriff hat ja sind gab es schon
eingeführt im moment bin ich hoffe sie
können uns jetzt auch alle oder haben
uns jetzt auch alle gehört ist denn der
atomausstieg es sind ja noch sechs am
netz wirklich aus ihrer sicht auch dass
er sie haben gesagt er ist nicht
sinnvoll aber ist er nicht doch
irreversibel
ja dieser ist jetzt reversibel weil die
ganzen entscheidungen ja schon getroffen
sind die brennstäbe das kernmaterial
wurde ja nicht nach gekauft die leute
wurden schon entlassen
ich weiß nicht wie man das jetzt noch
rückgängig machen will
die die die würfel sind gefallen nur es
ist eine katastrophale fehlentscheidung
für die deutsche wirtschaft in
deutschland hat er heute schon die
höchsten stromkosten in ganz europa
vermutlich in der gesamten
industrialisierten welt ja wir liegen
hier an der spitze und das belastet den
standorten und gibt man sondertarife für
die firmen dann wird der strom für also
für manche firmen
wird der strom für andere firmen und für
die verbraucher um so teurer
der grüne strom ist eben doch ziemlich
teuer
warum es ja so teuer die sonne schickt
zwar keine rechnung aber die
anlagenkosten schon eine menge geld und
die anlagen die grünen brauchen immer
die konventionellen als sogenannte back
up ersatzkraftwerke das heißt der grüne
strom geht rauf und runter rauf und
runter und wenn er untergeht müssen die
anderen gewehr bei fuß stehen und
liefern im grunde können wir kein
einziges konventionelles kraftwerk
abschalten wenn wir in den wind und
sonnenstrom gehen weil ja ab und zu
keinen wind ist und keine sonne
das heißt die kapazität muss voll und
ganz da sein die können wir temporär
sozusagen abschalten ja aber wir können
sie nicht voll vom netz nehmen die die
mannschaft dort muss in bereitschaft
sein
die anlagen müssen up to date gehalten
werden
es müssen auch neue kraftwerke gebaut
werden kann man ein bisschen
substituieren es muss ja nicht die kohle
sollen man kann auch das gas neben aber
innerhalb der klasse der konventionellen
kraftwerke können wir auf kapazität
nicht verzichten denn ein stabiles netz
braucht eine regelbare energie der wind
und sonnenstrom hat jan einspeise
privileg der wird immer abgenommen weil
es rechtlich so verfügt worden ist auch
wenn er gar nicht gebraucht wird
gute energie ist aber energie die man
auf bedarf zu einem zeitpunkt wo die
räder der industrie des morgens anfangen
zu laufen
zur verfügung stellt wo die leute wenn
sie ihr essen kochen strom brauchen dann
zusätzlich zur verfügung stellt und
diese fähigkeit hat der wind und
sonnenstrom hat kann er braucht also die
anderen wir haben also doppelte kosten
für diese grünen strukturen weil die
konventionellen ja nicht abgeschaltet
werden
das kommt hinzu sind wirklich ganz war
ja bitte
ja wenn
die wir in noch mehr grünen strom und
den marktanteil erhöhen kommt ein
nächstes nächste problem das in
günstigen zeiten wenn der wind weht und
die sonne scheint wir auch
überschießende spitzen haben frau
kämpfer sagt die sollte man halt
verklappen sollte man ungenutzt lassen
aber das ist natürlich ein gewaltiger
effizienzverlust und dieser zusätzliche
strom der in der überschießenden spitzen
da ist ist auch feuer zu verwerten und
man kann ihn verwerten indem man eine
wasserstoff technologie hat und so
weiter
nur die anlagen sind sehr sehr teuer und
können nur manchmal bedient werden wenn
die überschießenden spielt jetzt sagen
wir haben also dreifache kosten
grüne energie backup kraftwerke und
irgendwelche speicherlösung für die
überschießenden spitzen oder vernichtung
dieser überspielen sie haben jetzt eine
ganze reihe von von jemand aus der
steuer und komponenten sind kaempfert es
geht ja zunächst mal müssen sie
eigentlich so abarbeiten
die kalte dunkle flaute das ist im
januar keine sonne kein wind und wo
kommt dann der strom her
sie haben es gerade schon angedeutet es
gibt da einen energiemix es gibt
verschiedene möglichkeiten aber ist das
im moment jetzt gerade bei dieser
ausstiegs diskussion hier haben wirklich
realistisch zu glauben wir können uns
sind absehbarer zeit ausschließlich auf
regenerative energie konzentrieren oder
darauf verlassen dass es funktioniert ja
das können wir aber der energie oder die
energie system wende muss auch gestaltet
werden und wir müssen hier vom ende her
denken ich will ja auch neueste
energiewirtschaftliche erkenntnisse
hereinbringen die runde um auch noch mit
einigen mythen aufzuräumen
erstens sind auch konventionelle
kraftwerke nicht automatisch immer
versorgungssicher wir haben auch hier
schwankungen gerade auch bei der
atomenergie es gibt auch hier wetter
extreme im sommer wenn konventionelle
kraftwerke heruntergefahren werden
müssen auch diese schwankungen müssen
ausgeglichen werden das zweite ist die
erneuerbaren energien sind teamplayer
sie müssen zueinander geschaltet werden
und man muss nicht neben jeder
windanlage ein kohlekraftwerk stellen
das ist tatsächlich nicht notwendig
sondern es geht darum dass man eine
kluge vernetzung hat eine verzahnung
dass man auch entsprechend das
lastmanagement des energiemanagements so
einrichtet und zukunft hier auch
speicher dazu schaltet um auf diese zwei
wochen die ja alle so brennend
interessierte im januar dann auch
ausgerichtet zu sein alle studien
belegen dass dies möglich ist
und da muss man sich auch in die neue
auch in die neue energiewirtschaftliche
studium welt ein bisschen einarbeiten
und sehen das ist ihr veränderung geben
wird und in der tat hat das zukünftige
energiesysteme dann wenig noch mit dem
zu tun was wir aus der vergangenheit
kennen und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass man die rahmenbedingungen schafft
die erneuerbaren energien ausbauen
die digitalisierung voran bringt die
elektromobilität wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen der primärenergiebedarf mit
zurückgehen mit einem system aus
erneuerbaren energien aber der
strombedarf wird zunehmen und all das
stärkt das system und der letzte punkt
die kosten können sinken alle studien
belegen dass die energiesystem kosten
eines auf einer vollversorgung mit
erneuerbaren energien ausgerichtete
energiewelt geringer sind als die der
konventionellen energien wahl im moment
ist es ja so dass wir die kosten von
atom und kohle heimlich bezahlen die
klimakosten sowieso aber auch die
abbaukosten durch braunkohle und auch
die kosten durch die atomenergie alle
heimlich bezahlen um hingegen wir das
aktuell beim strompreis die zusätzlichen
investitionen in erneuerbare energien
auf den strompreis umlegen und alle den
eindruck erweckt bekommen dass es sich
hier um ein luxusgut handelt das
gegenteil ist richtig erneuerbare
energien werden billiger die
energiesystem kosten sinken und alle
können auch davon profitieren
also insofern können wir das auch
tatsächlich schaffen aber wir müssen
jetzt vom ende her denken und endlich
auch einstiegs diskussionen führen um
die besten wege dorthin gestalten zu
können
ich nehme gleich noch gedanken von herrn
sinn zweikämpfe nochmal auf verpasst wir
gehen ja immer grundsätzlich davon aus
wir brauchen jetzt möglichst natürlich
co2 geringen oder freien strom also
sauberen strom für unsere bedürfnisse
soll immer so viel strom da sein
wie wir gerade brauchen für unsere
bedürfnisse jetzt predigt ja frei bis
fünf user auch im zusammenhang mit der
klimakatastrophe von konsumverzicht zu
sagen wir machen bestimmte dinge einfach
zurückfahren die er dieser wohlstand
dieser materielle wohlstand um jeden
preis das kann nicht mehr sein dass
belastet die umwelt das belastet das
klima zu sehr muss das müssen wir
unseren blick auch ändern auf diese
frage dass wir immer das zur verfügung
haben was wir brauchen also gerade das
strom eben in unmengen da sein muss weil
wir eben nach wie vor diesen wohlstand
diesen materiellen wohlstand haben
wollen
ich würde ihnen erst mal nur bedingt
zustimmen also falls natürlicher predigt
erstmal gar nichts und vor allem nicht
die konsumkritik wir sagen ganz klar
dass wir strukturell und systemische
probleme sehen und die dann auch
bekämpfen müssen deswegen geht es nicht
darum was wir einzelne dafür tun können
und wie viel strom wie einzelne
konsumieren die sagen ganz klar dass wir
eine sozial ökologische transformation
brauchen auch dann in der energie- und
energiewende und strom wände und wir
verstehen uns als klimagerechtigkeit
bewegung und da müssen wir auch als
gesellschaft hier im globalen neuen uns
die frage stellen wollen wir auf den auf
kosten anderer leben wollen wir den
globalen süden ausbeuten also sei es
jetzt auch die elektro elektromobilität
aber auch halt die atomenergie die die
ressourcen müssen irgendwo herkommen und
die kommen nun mal aus der ausbeutung
von frauen und kindern im globalen süden
und das sind die das sind fragen die wir
uns stellen die stein und globale
gerechtigkeit fragen und verständnis
natürlich auch fragen der sozialen
gerechtigkeit hier im land also dass die
energie zentral geregelt oder ist die
energie dann im bürger/innen hand ist
die energie dezentral regel und das sind
fragen die wir voranbringen wollen wo
wir ganz klar sagen wir müssen diesen
diskurs ankurbeln um über den einstieg
zu reden um über erneuerbare energien zu
reden und auch dann ganz klar zu sagen
keine brückentechnologien und keine
ungerechten neuen neokolonialen
perspektiven auf das heißt für sie ist
klimafragen energieerzeugung
energiepolitik weniger eine ökologische
eine ökonomische als eine soziale frage
sowohl als auch es ist alles es ist
immer ökonomisch sozial und auch nur
kulturell gesellschaftlich der frage wie
können nur die ganzen politischen
maßnahmen führen mit gesellschaftlichen
mehrheiten wir brauchen aber auch
natürlich die wissenschaft und da sei
kempf hat ja ganz klar dass wir die
studien haben dass sie die
machbarkeitsstudien haben dass wir ganz
klare wissenschaftliche evidenz haben
dass wir diese ganzen forderungen die ja
die bewegung stellt ganz klar umsetzen
können wir sind ja umgeben von einer
ganzen reihe von ländern in europa also
unmittelbaren nachbarstaaten belgien
frankreich tschechien und da aber auch
noch an der peripherie einige der auf
atomkraft setzen die erstens die
atomkraftwerke gar nicht abgeschaltet
haben und sogar noch neue bauen wollen
also auf diese atomenergie setzen wie
soll denn das funktionieren dass so
unterschiedliche energiesysteme
innerhalb der europäischen union zu
nebeneinanderher existieren und wir dann
auch noch gleichzeitig sagen gott sei
dank haben wir vielleicht auch noch den
unbeliebten schmutzigen atomstrom aus
frankreich sind uns der dann bei
stromausfall kurzzeitig über die bühne
hilft ich glaube das ist dass das ist ja
eigentlich einerseits das geschenk und
auf der anderen seite der der rücken auf
dem der deutsche atomausstieg eben
stattgefunden hat bisher das was frau
kaempfert sagt mag ja richtig sein und
ich glaube auch dass es richtig ist aber
es ist eben heute nicht realität und die
heutige realität heute ist halt dass wir
aus der atomkraft aussteigen und das für
den atomstrom von anderen importieren
weil es eben mit abstrichen und nicht
perfekt aber es gibt eben europäischen
netze in denen strom fließt in denen
strom gehandelt wird verkauft wird und
gekauft wird und deutschland exportiert
seinen seinen alternativen strom seien
erneuerbaren strom in spitzenzeiten eben
zu negativ kosten nach österreich um ihn
dann wieder zurückzukaufen und das ist
gewollt so das ist auch richtig dass
preise abgebildet werden aber es zeigt
eben auch die absurdität eines systems
in dem eben es keinen konsens darüber
gibt welche energieformen die zukunft
bestimmen wird und haben wir zu viel
oder zu wenig strom moment das hängt
immer hängt immer davon ab was wir haben
im moment denn wenn wir die beiderseits
laufender über und dann nichts mehr
wieder nach strom
der pfingstmontag ist einer der
beliebtesten tage von von strom planern
weil man dann eben immer auf 100
erneuerbar kommen kann das in der regel
ist es dann schon einigermaßen warm die
sonne scheint die tage sind lang und
manchmal hat man eben auch so einen ganz
frischen frühlingswind dazu dann sieht
man eine wirklich tolle welt wo alles
erneuerbar ist und wo man eben im grunde
halt alle fossile energie abschalten
könnte
und eben auch dann zu viel energie hat
natürlich an anderen tagen eben diese
berühmte kalte dunkle flaute dann gibt
es zu wenig und wenn man dann noch sagt
wir wollen aber die energiewende im
wesentlichen als strom wende machen dann
kommen ja ganz großkunden dazu also die
chemische industrie zum beispiel die
stellt heute ihre primär energie selber
her und verfeuert halten sie rohstoffe
wenn sie das nicht mehr tut dann hat sie
eben eine enorme strombedarf der nach
oben drauf kommt und wenn man das dann
alles erneuerbar haben will dann hat man
entweder supergute netze die eben in
europa überall da wo erneuerbarer strom
produziert werden kann das dann eben
auch in die industriellen zentren der
nach deutschland schaffen kann
oder man hat oder oder man hat ein
problem
frau kämpfen was die diesen dieser diese
regenerative energie diesen sauberen
strom der ja sauber ist weil er in der
natur entsteht und zunächst mal dort in
der natur auch keine kosten verursacht
aber was das problem macht ist ja dass
einerseits es ärger gibt wegen der
windkraft aber wir brauchen mehr
windkraft trader noch da gibt es jetzt
diskussionen wegen der abstandsregel zu
dörfern auch wegen der wegen der
lärmbelästigung da gibt es
bürgerinitiativen dann fehlen uns auch
vor allem für den transport regenerative
energien aus dem norden in den süden
dort wo entsteht und dort wo er
gebraucht wird stromtrassen
hochleistungs stromtrassen da gibt es
auch massive widerstände dann müssen
auch noch pumpspeicherwerke für die
speicherkapazitäten gebaut werden das
mit auch nicht überall gesehen das nennt
man ja in der deutschen politik nimmt
not in my backyard nicht in meiner
nachbarschaft alles tolle idee bloß
nicht bei mir soll es nicht gebaut
werden ist das eine wesentliche hypothek
für die energie
ende ja also darum muss es vor allen
dingen gehen dass wir in richtung
akzeptanz sehr viel mehr machen also auf
der einen seite ist es richtig dass wir
ein zubau ja auch brauchen
von den erneuerbaren energien und bei
den windanlagen gibt es jetzt
möglichkeiten dass man auch in kommunen
finanzielle beteiligungsverfahren
ermöglicht oder auch andere formen der
partizipation wir kennen aus der
akzeptanz forschung dass es da auch gute
wege geben kann aber wir reden ja nicht
nur über wind solarenergie verkennen wir
immer sie können auf jedes dach wo das
möglich ist in deutschland solarenergie
bauen ohne dass sie die ganzen konflikte
haben und haben damit eine dezentrale
form der energiewende die man dann auch
direkt in quartieren in häusern nutzen
kann wenn sie noch batterien koppeln
können sie auch die dezentralen netze
entlasten
das ist ganz wichtig und es wird aber
auch darauf ankommen dass wir überall in
deutschland erneuerbare energien
ausbauen also dass wir jetzt einzelne
bundesländer haben die sehr stark auf
der bremse stehen weil sie eigene
regelung machen bayern nordrhein
westfalen wo der windenergie ausbau
nicht vorankommt da brauchen wir
bundeseinheitliche regelung denn wir
brauchen in der tat die erneuerbaren
energien überall um gerade nicht in
solche situationen zu kommen wo man dann
sagt wir bauen nur im norden auf shore
windenergie und brauchen das dann im
süden
zumal wir auch im norden dann nach
möglichkeit auf wasserstoff elektrolyse
anlagen haben werden die dann auch den
kraftstoff produzieren den wir an
anderer stelle brauchen also das ist die
energie system wende auf die es ankommt
aber noch ein satz zu heute weil eben
immer gesagt wurde
wir importieren strom
wir sind noch immer nettoexporteur das
heißt auch in frankreich wenn dort die
kraftwerke im heißen sommer
runtergefahren werden exportieren wir
unseren strom dorthin also man kann die
geschichte auch immer anders rum noch
drehen aber in der zukunft mit wichtig
dass wir wirklich über die zukunft
sprechen
und da auch die rahmenbedingungen so zu
setzen dass eben diese transformation
voran geht und wir mit der dezentralen
energiewende darauf ankommen wo wir hin
wollen dann wenn sie von der zukunft
gerne die frage nochmal speichertechnik
das wird ja immer genannt gerade um
diese spitzenfrau weiten feld hat das ja
gerade auch geschildert diesen ausgleich
zu viel zu wenig um speicher anzusetzen
dass man den strom dann zur verfügung
hat wenn man ihn braucht aber diese
speicher technik befindet sich in
kinderschuhen wir machen doch irgendwie
energiewirtschaftliche luftbuchungen im
moment mit einer technik die noch gar
nicht so zur verfügung steht
nein das stimmt mich sie ist technisch
zur verfügung könnten sie auch heute
schon einsetzen wir haben batteriekosten
die sinken kontinuierlich und wirklich
im freien fall batterien können
eingesetzt werden wir haben die von
ihnen angesprochenen
pumpspeicherkraftwerke in der tat kommt
es darauf an dass wir die auch ausbauen
und nutzen auch im süden österreich
schweiz sitzenden oder auch norwegen und
in der zukunft werden wir mittel- und
langfristiger auch benötigen dazu gehört
der wasserstoff und auch ein
synthetisches gas was wird aus
wasserstoff gewinnen können diese
technik ist bekannt wir können sie
einsetzen aber sie ist heute noch recht
teuer und deswegen müssen wir die
rahmenbedingungen anpassen fördern und
die möglichkeiten schaffen dass die
technik auch zum einsatz kommen das sind
ich würde gerne noch ein aspekt
ansprechen der auch dazugehört und der
möglicherweise der atomenergie oder auch
den befürwortern überhaupt diesen
energiesystem das genick brechen könnte
das ist die ungelöste endlagerfrage ist
das nicht die eigentliche achillesferse
schon immer gewesen der produktion von
atomenergie dass uns da atommüll viele
hunderttausend jahre
noch bleibt der zum teil ganz heftig
strahlt naja sie wurde dazu gemacht die
meisten länder haben dieses endlager
problem gar nicht weil sie vor ort
lagern um später über schnelle brüter
die brennstäbe noch einmal zu verwerten
und es gibt ja neue reaktortypen die im
gespräch sind bill gates will ja da groß
auch investieren die in der lage sind
aus den ausgebrannten brennstäbe noch
einmal energie rauszuholen was im
prinzip
die rest strahlung nach dieser wieder
verwertung auf ein sechstel reduzieren
kann das sind zwar ein problem aber sind
ja winzig kleine mengen im verhältnis zu
dem co2 dass wir in der atmosphäre
ablagern wir benutzen die atmosphäre als
mülldeponie ist es keine technik ohne
nebenwirkungen aber diese nebenwirkung
hält sich ja doch glaube ich in grenzen
viele leute wissen ja nicht dass die
strahlung ja doch eine relativ
natürliche angelegenheit ist also die
erde strahlt wenn sie thermische energie
aus der erde holen durch eine bohrung
das machen ja viele leute dann haben sie
die hälfte der energie aus kernkraft ja
das sind radioaktive zerfallsprozesse
die die andere hälfte ist ist die
bremswirkung des des eisen kerns aber
radioaktivität begleitet das leben auf
dieser erde von anbeginn an
aber er 97 mal zerlegt sich in der
stadtpolitik mit der die deutsche
politik zerlegt sich im moment wegen
dieser endlagerfrage das ist ja auch
eine eine standort im schweizerischen
zug
damals haben wir uns von herrn trittin
denen ich ja sehr schätze als person
dass ein gesagt haben braucht dieses
endlager und solange man es nicht hat
kann es nicht weiter gehen also
dieses problem haben alle anderen länder
gelöst
wir haben ja ganz viele länder die
tatsächlich atomkraft haben in
deutschland ist hier eigentlich der
geisterfahrer mit seinem ausstieg sie
haben es ja schon erwähnt die franzosen
am 70 71 prozent ihrer stromversorgung
aus kernenergie auch die schweden ja die
schweden hatten ursprünglich mal ein
ausstiegs beschluss gefasst nach
harrisburg 1980 haben sie den gefasst
ein jahr nach diesem unfall
sie wollten aussteigen sind aber nie
wirklich ausgestiegen und haben
inzwischen beschlossen die kraftwerke
dauerhaft weiterzubetreiben 40 prozent
des stroms in schweden kommt aus
kernkraft nicht oder tschechien 35
prozent belgien 48 prozent aber
deutschland will auf null und die ganzen
kraftwerke liegen wenn sie mal so eine
landkarte anschauen im westen von
deutschland wenn es also wirklich mal
ein fallout gibt und wir haben
normalerweise ja westwinde dann ist er
das gebiet wo der dann stattfindet zu
100 prozent fast auf deutschem
territorium was haben wir denn überhaupt
davon gewonnen wenn wir aussteigen und
beziehen den strom dann aus den ländern
die westlich von uns angesiedelt sind
und dann ein richtiges geschäft und das
ist ja das ist ja das funktioniert all
diese atomkatastrophe ja dann uns in
nachbarländern auch treffen würde
herr page green dienen das ist auch so
dann wenn schon dann mach es doch lieber
unter eigener kontrolle deutschland hat
diese technik erfunden
dafür gab es die erste novelle oder aber
die halle jetzt wir könnten das
natürlich besser und sicherer hand haben
als andere länder
dieser atomausstieg nicht haben sind
haben wir gesagt dass diese atomausstieg
trotzdem jetzt irreversibel ist ich
möchte ganz gerne herbst auf diesen
aspekt des kanadier ist nicht jetzt im
moment haben sie gesagt im moment macht
es keinen sinn da ja immer um im moment
geht es nicht mehr aber warum bauen wir
nicht neue kraftwerke erforschen neue
kraftwerkstypen wie das an vielen
stellen der welt
und investieren in noch sichere
netzwerke übrigen was die unsicherheit
betrifft wenn sie mal die zahl der toten
neben relativ zu der erzeugten energie
wissen sie was die sicherste kraft
energie ist tatsächlich die kernkraft am
unsichersten ist die kohle wegen der
vielen krebsfälle aber auch wegen der
vielen zehntausend tote in den
kraftwerken jedes jahr erdgas das ist
alles vielfach teurer und selbst wind
und also vielfach gefährlicher und
selbst wind und solarenergie ist
gefährlicher als ein atomkraftwerk haben
relativ zu der erzeugten energie jedes
jahr auf der welt bei der herstellung
dieser anlagen und den betrieb dieser
anlage aufs dach klettern und so weiter
haben die wieder verlieren wir werden
als durch die atomkritische okay ich
habe natürlich ist angekommen
dieser dieser statistik was uns da von
opfern kommt ich wollte gerne auf diesen
kleinen die noch eingehen in der
europäischen union was die
kommissionspräsidentin da jetzt
vorgeschlagen hat ist ja nicht zuletzt
auch auf druck ihrer organisation hin
entstanden die diskussion in den letzten
zwei jahren so ein bisschen in
vergessenheit geraten durch corona aber
das ist ja genau das problem wir haben
in europa herr sinn hat es jetzt gerade
ausführlich gesagt ganz unterschiedliche
energiepolitik auch ganz
unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten wie kann
man sich denn eine klimafreundliche
zukunft in europa vorstellen wenn diese
völlig unterschiedlichen energiearten
mit unterschiedlichen emissionen so viel
kohle im spiel in osteuropa überhaupt so
zum tragen kommen wie wie stellen sie
sich unter diesen ganz unterschiedlichen
aspekte mit den ganz unterschiedlichen
voraussetzungen eigentlich die zukunft
die klimazukunft in europa vor
das ist die große frage also ich bin
jetzt 20 jahre alt klima aktiv ist und
war wohl wahrlich kein experte dafür und
habe auch leider hier keine kugel wo ich
rein schauen kann
ich stelle mir ganz klar die nachhaltige
zukunft so vor dass wir auf erneuerbare
energien hundertprozentig setzen dass
wir eine komplette sozialer ökonomischer
transformationen haben jetzt sagt das
sehr oft jetzt schon weil wir immer
nicht vergessen dürfen dass die
ökologische und ökonomische
transformation nur mit der sozialen
gerechtigkeit einher gehen darf und das
nicht nur auf einer europäischen ebene
sondern auf einer globalen ebene wir
dürfen nicht weiter darauf setzen dass
unser wohlstand hier in europa darauf
basiert das
menschen woanders ausbeuten vor allem
nie im globalen süden oder auch die
ressourcen des gemeinwesens weiterhin
ausbeuten und wenn wir über
gefährlichkeit ein risiko reden
da muss man auch ganz klar sagen dass ja
mit atomkraftwerken auch irgendwo das
potenzial die potenzielle gefahr von
atomwaffen existiert und das endlager
die frage ja auch eine frage von
generationengerechtigkeit ist also wohl
war nicht haben wir die frage noch nicht
gelöste wo die ganzen atommüll wo der
atommüll hingehen soll weil wir die ein
so langes der pfalz haben
das ist ja weiter von generation zu
generation getragen wird und wenn wir
wenn frau kämpfen sagt wir haben die
energien schon wir haben die techniken
schon wieso in das tier wir denn nicht
wie du stein würde nicht da ein und
sagen die subventionieren diese
erneuerbaren angehen wieso müssen wir
jetzt darüber diskutieren dass wir in
ein laufwerk reaktor von bill gates
investieren der noch in kinderschuhen
ist und dann irgendwann vielleicht diese
atomkraftwerke zu bauen und dann
vielleicht irgendwann co2 neutrale
energie durch atomenergie zu erschaffen
also das sind ja fragen die so lange hin
sich ziehen das ja gar nichts trinken
wir wenig von zehn jahren und zehn jahre
besiegte punkte überschritten werden
deswegen müssen wir jetzt handeln und
jetzt einsteigen
green deal in europa wie soll das
funktionieren mit unter dem aspekt
glauben will die klimabilanz verbessern
es gibt klare vorgaben jetzt auch für
2030 2040 2050 mit einem solchen
unterschiedlichen energiekonzept kann
das funktionieren
naja man muss die klima ziele erreichen
und das ist also eben nicht man will
muss sondern man muss und deshalb muss
eben auch dieser green deal
funktionieren ich meine man kann beim
besten willen nicht behaupten dass grüne
energien erneuerbare energie nicht so
funktioniert würden im moment die werden
schon subventioniert aber das kann
natürlich kann so etwas funktionieren
wenn wir alles nutzen was wir wissen und
was wir kennen und wenn da eben in
einzelnen ländern atomkraftwerke dazu
gehören dann gehört es auch zum green
deal und so ähnlich verhält sich die
europäische union ja auch dass wir das
in deutschland nicht wollen
ich glaube das muss man akzeptieren das
ist konsens im land und dann jetzt
dagegen anzukämpfen das ist ein kampf
gegen windmühlen aber die energie die
man hat darauf zu verwenden zu sagen
lasst uns gucken
dass wir die erneuerbaren möglicherweise
eben mit einem europäischen konzept so
kombinieren dass es dann am ende auch
nicht so schlimm ist wenn man mal
atomstrom aus frankreich kaufte das
glaube ich ist der vernünftige weg man
muss eben pragmatisch sein wenn man das
erreichen will was freilich verfügt
finde ich zu recht fordert nun die
rechte welt eine klimaneutrale welt dann
muss man eben auch pragmatisch handeln
und darf eben nicht ideologisch sich
entweder dafür oder dagegen so auf den
punkt stellen dass man sich nicht mehr
bewegen kann vorkämpfer wie sie denn das
pragmatische handeln dann aus wenn wir
uns mal ansehen dass länder wie die usa
da gibt es jetzt auch ein neues programm
russland vor allem china auch die türkei
japan offensichtlich in den nächsten
jahrzehnten möglicherweise sogar bis zum
ende des jahrhunderts auf atomenergie
setzen also einen ganz anderen weg gehen
wie müssen wir uns da als atomfreien
zone in europa aufstellen ja also erst
mal sind wir da in deutschland nicht
alleine auch andere europäische länder
machen ein atomausstieg die schweiz
italien schon lange abgeschlossen
österreich nie eingestiegen spanien
plant ist andere länder auch aber die
usa oder andere länder diese erwähnt ist
eine wichtige komponente das ist die
marktwirtschaft und atomenergie ist
einfach extrem teuer
und dazu gehört auch eine kostenwahrheit
wir sehen dass der ein kraftwerk was in
finnland gebaut wird fast zehnmal so
teuer ist als ursprünglich geplant und
auch in england muss man über 35 jahre
subventionieren damit man ein kraftwerk
baut da es sind noch nicht die kosten
des rückbaus drin und auch der ewig
strahlen des ewig strahlenden atommülls
der uns noch 30.000 generationen
beschäftigen wird er einfach zu sagen es
gibt keine strahlung und die erde
strahlt das das da muss man wirklich
massiv widersprechen
es ist eine sehr kostspielige
technologie und das regelt sich in den
ländern wo kosten eine rolle spielen von
alleine die amerikaner werden nicht in
diese neue technik im großen stil
investieren wir haben dafür auch nicht
die kosten die da tatsächlich bezahlt
werden in anderen ländern russland china
oder andere
die eben staatswirtschaft liechtenstein
entscheiden die bauen im moment
atomkraftwerke weil sie das mit ihrem
staatsbudget tun und wir auch
feststellen in unserer studie dass es
dort wenig demokratischer beteiligung
gibt und das kann man so machen aber das
löst die atom probleme in keinster weise
die endlager probleme nicht die risiko
der risiken die damit einher geht also
insofern ist es tatsächlich keine
ideologische entscheidung sondern eine
marktwirtschaftliche und wir haben
billigere technologien es sind die
erneuerbaren energien inklusive aller
techniken die damit einhergehen das
bietet enorme wirtschaftliche chancen
und da wird auch die werden die usa ganz
sicher auch in die richtung gehen und da
bin ich setze man sich allein als guten
konnte ich sehr zuversichtlich dass das
gibt es sicherlich noch großen
gesprächsbedarf hier auch in der runde
jetzt ist die runde leider beschränkt
auf 44 minuten und 30 sekunden und der
zehnte jahrestag der atomkatastrophe hat
uns die gelegenheit gegeben dieses thema
mal wieder aufzunehmen offenbar ist das
thema atomenergie noch nicht ganz durch
ich bedanke mich bei claudia kemfert bei
hans werner sinn bei ursula weidenfeld
und bei quantas für die teilnahme an der
sendung liebe zuschauer am sonntag 16
uhr 30 wahlsendung bei phoenix ist die
landtagswahl in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz wir berichten den ganzen
abend ausführlich mit den hochrechnungen
gleichzeitig von ard und zdf am montag
ab 8 uhr dann die wahlnachlese und am
montagabend 22 uhr 15 ebenfalls
wahlnachlese in unserer gesprächssendung
unter den linden mit eva lindenau
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit sarah
bilder und da gehen wir auch nochmal auf
fukushima 1
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]